>> ♪ ♪
FALSE INFORMATION ON SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS.
MOST ARE NOT SCHOOL SHOOTINGS AT
ALL.
TWO ARE SUICIDES.
ONE A BEE-BEE GUN FIRED AT A
SCHOOL BUS WINDOW BUT THOSE ARE
NOT SCHOOL SHOOTINGS.
A RADIO SHOW HOST AND
SPOKESWOMAN FOR THE NRA JOINS
US.
FIRST, THEY SAID THERE WERE 11
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS.
HOW MANY HAVE THERE BEEN?
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING ME.
HOW THEY DEFINE A SCHOOL
SHOOTING.
THEY SAY THIS IS HOW THE FBI
DESCRIBES MASS SHOOTING, BUT THE
FBI DOESN'T USE THE PHRASE MASS
KILLING.
EVEN THEN THEY HAVE A NUMERICAL
VALUE.
THE FBI DOESN'T CONSIDER
SOMETHING TO BE A MASS MURDER
UNLESS YOU LOOK AT 4 OR MORE
PERPETRATOR WHO WAS KILLING
OTHER PEOPLE.
THE NUMBERS PUSHED BY EVERY TOWN
WHICH HAS DONE THIS OVER AND
OVER AGAIN FOR YEAR AFTER YEAR,
THAT'S IN NO WAY ACCURATE.
THERE HAVE BEEN SCHOOL SHOOTINGS
THIS YEAR.
UNLIKE WHAT YOU HEAR REPEATED IN
THE MEDIA AND IN HEADLINES.
THEY ARE RARE.
THEY DO NOT OCCUR OFTEN BUT THEY
GET A LOT OF MEDIA COVERAGE
BECAUSE IT'S A SCARY THING.
THIS IS WHAT THIS GROUP WANTS TO
DO:
EXPLOIT THAT AND BANK ON THAT AS
POLICY POSITION AND FUND RAISE
OFF OF THAT PARTICULAR FEAR
MONGERING.
IT'S NOT ACCURATE WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE.
I WANT TO NOTE AS WELL.
YOU MENTIONED THE OTHER MEDIA
OUTLETS THAT REPEATED.
IN EVERY TOWN, THEY HAVE DONE
THIS BEFORE.
TUCKER, YOU MENTIONED THEY
AND INCLUDED IT IN MY FIRST GUN.
NEAR A SCHOOL.
THEY INCLUDED AN ARGUMENT
BETWEEN TWO GROWN MEN, IT
HAPPENED IN A SCHOOL PARKING
LOT.
KILLING.
NONE OF IT IS GOOD, BUT YOU
SHOULD NOT LIE ABOUT IT.
FACTS MATTER.
I APPRECIATE THAT YOU ASSEMBLED